there are growing calls for conspiracy
theorist alex jones to be
arrested for threatening comments that
he made about president-elect joe biden
over the weekend at the supposed million
maga rally in dc
which fell just just a little bit short
of a million people
and alex jones talked about removing joe
biden
one way or another that was the language
he used take a look
and it's in the midst of this absolutely
unhinged rant i understand
the video quality is not good in this
clip it's actually atrocious
this is the best we were able to find
take a look we will never back down
to the satanic pedophile globalist new
world order
and their walking dead reanimated
corpse joe biden
and we will never recognize him
trump president trump had zero
connection to russians
no proof four years of investigation
with the biden's hits open and shut
so i don't know who's going to the white
house in 38 days
but i sure know this joe biden
is a globalist and joe biden will be
removed
one way or another
now one way or another suggests violence
it it alludes to assassination
given that joe biden won and
states certified the wins and the
electors voted
and that joe biden will be sworn in on
january 20th and the scariest thing
about all of this
is that someone as prominent as alex
jones
ranting like this is bad enough but alex
jones is doing the rant in front of
exactly the type of crowd that might
actually get some ideas from hearing
alex jones say this stuff
and that really gets into the bulk of
the issue that
i i want to confront we have to confront
and i'm not exactly sure how
alex jones lawyers have previously said
in court that he's playing a character
on his show
now that's a very common legal defense
for these types when they say insane
things they will say it it's a character
but that video clip i played for you is
not from a show it's a political rally
it's a political event
and alex jones is still saying these
things but fair enough
maybe simply saying it in these terms we
have to remove joe biden one way or
another maybe he doesn't mean violence
maybe he means impeachment or something
maybe it doesn't rise to anything beyond
mere political opinion
but it's not just that this is a crowd
that might fall for it
and do something thanks to alex jones
without
diagnosing anyone if you watch alex
jones and think he's a journalist
or someone giving you good information
like i know people who watch him as mere
entertainment
sort of like shock value or uh you know
disaster porn okay
but if you watch alex jones and think
you're getting information from a
journalist
and that maybe that's information that
that you could act on
you probably have some issues yourself
and i'm not vaguely throwing around the
term mentally ill and i know that it
would be fraught to do that
but i think that we can all understand
that the people most likely to see alex
jones rants as a source of news and take
them to heart are people
that he is exploiting who have very real
issues of different kinds
let's put it that way without diagnosing
anything and so
the question of how far playing a
character goes is a real practical
uh a serviceable question jones lawyer
stated on the record that jones is
playing a character
and is a performance artist and argued
that you can't judge alex jones based on
what he says on his show
that it would be like judging jack
nicholson when he played the joker
in batman which by the way was the first
movie i saw when i moved to the u.s
back in 1989 1990. but way more people
know when they watch batman and they see
the joker they know it's fiction
they know these are actors the people
who would hear alex jones and think okay
he's sort of a news guy
in some way they are really
doing something that is a much more
precarious situation
batman and joker are obvious characters
alex jones is acting like a real person
who's acting under his own name and
that's why the legal argument that his
lawyers made falls apart
but it doesn't matter because he's still
influencing people's behavior
i actually believe the better analogy is
pro wrestling
where wrestlers sometimes wrestle under
their real names
and uh are are performing in a way
that's intended to get people to suspend
disbelief it sort of looks like real
wrestling
and case in point if a pro wrestler
whether in character or not
made a threat to an elected official i
think the secret service would
immediately act on it to see if it's a
real threat so this is very very low
and uh we we really have a perfect storm
here we have trump insisting it was
rigged oan and newsmax supporting it and
giving giving oxygen to these ideas
and people like alex jones and the my
pillow guy mike lindell and others
fueling the fire and it could get very
ugly very quickly
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts
because all of their shirts come with a
patented zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but
most importantly just overall it makes
the shirt fit
much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout